I heard a story about you and I don't
know if it's true but it sounds like you
this is not a good intro I'm not loving
this he's never end well apparently
there was a series of murders no I'm
kidding this sounds very Luke Wilson to
me that you once ran the LA Marathon on
the spur of the moment with no training
and no rest is that a fake story or is
that real
it wasn't the spur of the moment we
decided that night at about I'd say 3:30
in the morning that we would make our
way down to the starting line at 7:00
that morning and tried the race but no
it's we just got into town and me and
this friend Danny find it we've had a
rather robust evening and got to talking
where most guys would say hey tomorrow
yeah we should go down and watch the
marathon we should he said let's run
this damn thing let's let's show these
guys who we are and it's like I can't
really imagine any of the great Kenyan
and Nigerian runners deciding at the
spur of the moment last minute
hey let's close down this bar go get a
couple burritos and then make our way to
be to the start line of the LA Marathon
but that is what we did I didn't finish
it but I made it I made it 22 miles
really you ran 22 miles with no training
and no rest hung over it sounds like
yeah I don't hit the hungover phase yet
so that might have been what kept me
going those 22
yeah it's still there there's a
jack-in-the-box on Sunset and that's
where I kind of took my last steps and I
walked in there and got some food and
then I had to just lay down on the
sidewalk and this woman very kind woman
marathon fan laid one of those silver
blankets over me and then and then I
picked up my friend but yeah I don't I
don't recommend doing that but it is
that kind of can-do spirit that we had
back then that I worry that sometimes
the Millennials today don't have like I
can't really see them going out doing
the marathon with no training I think a
big criticism of young people today is
that they don't have frankly the guts to
drink until 3 o'clock in the morning and
then go run a marathon and then collapse
in front of a jack-in-the-box
they don't have that spirit that I think
our generation has sometimes to be
courageous you have to be a dumbass
Conan that's that's tombstone material
not for me but yeah some other guy
that's good to Laura